I am very happy that our suggestion
that we can guarantee and
improve Polish security with Patriots
has been taken
up  the
Secretary of Defense and Lamprecht very
grateful for their very practical
ongoing effort to move this
forward and the construction will
be similar or identical to
what is being organized with regard to the appropriate systems already installed by
the United States and
Britain.
Russia's invasion of
Ukraine marks one  Walls of time
that required a strong, resolute response from
the allies, first and foremost
a response from the G7
it was possible to give this resolute
response the economically
strongest democracies in the world have moved
even closer together than they did
without it w  aren Democracy The
rule of law and human rights unite
us as valued partners in the fight for
a just world